[Music]
the Wellness Center in Manhattan Ville
is going to be providing a very critical
service to the community at the Jerome
Green Science Center I will be running
with a stellar team a community health
worker training institute so we are
going to be recruiting community members
from churches from community-based
organizations
senior centers housing projects anyone
who is really committed to the issue of
health and advocacy and we are going to
be empowering these individuals to not
only be advocates for health in their
communities but also to be able to
deliver very basic what I call
primordial health care services within
the community
we call it the community health worker
stroke prevention program it's based on
the community health worker model which
is using people who live in a community
as health workers to actually go out and
assist people in getting in for medical
care well I've learned a couple of
things how to take high blood pressure
and also how to measure for diabetes and
I think those things are important
because our community is
disproportionately affected with these
two diseases and instead of having to
wait on doctors and professionals to
come in to do this for the community we
will be able to do it ourselves I do
feel that this has been a great
experience because you learn so much
more than the motivation and the
compassion and just knowing what
different illnesses are that inflict on
people every day we're suffering so much
from high blood pressure from diabetes
from cancer from not having a proper
health insurance so all of these
different pieces of information we're
learning so that we can bring it to the
congregation and present it so that they
can become healthier yeah the church
they attend and serve the congregation
is predominantly Hispanic and one of the
things that I was talking to my pastor
about was about like health so we will
teach and empower these individuals with
the skills of motivational interview the
interviewing that they can take into
their communities and we will also
empower them with technical know-how to
screen individuals at least blood
pressure screening cholesterol screening
diabetes screening I can give you a pill
for high blood pressure but I can't
address all the things in society that
makes it hard to lower that pipe blood
pressure our communities and our society
is what we need to fix that problem we
are involving people who help us guide
people on how to navigate the health
insurance field to get where they need
to get to get in to see a doctor we are
providing referrals we are linking to a
community center where people can walk
in and sit down and have their blood
pressure check so it has been an
inspiration to me
it's gonna give me the wherewithal to go
out and do more than what I'm doing now
so it's been a pleasure meeting and
working with the people here and I want
to come in a commend Colombia for
bringing this kind of program into this
community so the Wellness Center is
going to be providing a very critical
service to the community and it's going
to become very quickly one of the the
pearls of the Columbia system